m.c escher has nothing on this place  chan baori is one of the largest and  perhaps most visually spectacular  stepwells  this deep four-sided structure is made  up of 3 500 escheresque terraced steps  that descend down to a depth of 100 feet  a large temple adorns the face  dedicated to harshat mata  goddess of joy and happiness  you may recognize this incredible wonder  its intricate steps have made  appearances in hollywood films like the  fall  the dark knight rises and the best  exotic marigold hotel  northwestern india where the stepwell  lies is extremely arid the well was  designed to conserve as much water as  possible  at the bottom of the well the air  remains five degrees cooler than at the  surface making it an excellent gathering  place for locals during intense heat  waves